- Hey everyone, it's Mark
Wiens in Bangkok, Thailand
and today we're taking a
day trip to one of the most
famous floating markets in Thailand.
It's called Amphawa floating market
and we're gonna go pick up Mike Chen.
He's another amazing food guy.
He loves to eat and he's in
Thailand right now hanging out
and we're gonna give you
a full tour of Amphawa.
How to get there, what to
do, and most importantly,
some incredibly delicious food.
We're gonna eat a bunch of delicious food.
So keep watching this
video, a full Amphawa
floating market tour guide coming up.
- All right, met up with Mike.
We are driving on our way to Amphawa.
It's located in a province
called Samut Songkhram
which is about an hour
and a half from Bangkok
but this is a really
popular floating market.
Especially a lot of Bangkok
people go there for the weekend
to eat, to hang out, to
enjoy, so it's gonna be cool
to go there and eat with Mike.
- I'm excited, I mean I have
cold noodles that's on land,
now maybe I'll get some
actually on a boat.
(upbeat music)
- All right, we just made it to Amphawa.
This is one of the most
famous and one of the biggest
and probably one of the
busiest floating markets
in all of Thailand.
This is an afternoon floating market
so it opens up about 2 or 3 p.m. is when
it really gets started and
when a lot of people come here.
And we are now just entering the main,
one of the main alleys.
There's food clustered
on both sides of us.
All the snacks you can imagine.
You can just come here and eat non-stop.
There's a lot of food to choose from.
There's so many different things
so we have decided to stop
for some fried fish cakes.
In Thai, they're called
(speaking foreign language).
And then we also got, we're gonna order
just some fried quail eggs.
- [Mike] They're so pretty.
- [Mark] They are.
And it's just so pure
man, it's just an egg.
- There's some chili
seasoning she put on there.
I can't wait to have it.
All right, so what do
you want to try first?
The fried fish cake?
- Yeah sure, let's try
the fried fish cakes.
- Let's do it.
- And these are, it's a
combination of minced fish
with curry paste so it has
some curry flavor in it
and these are fried whole basil leaves.
All right.
- Oh.
- Oh, it's really juicy.
- That's three ohs, and
that means it's good.
Woah.
- That is very tasty.
- That's delicious, that's delicious.
- [Mark] Airy, spongey, it's
packed, you can really taste
the curry paste in there,
the red curry paste in there.
- It's got some kick to it.
Next up we got these little quail eggs,
which they caught my eye
because they're so pretty.
And they're sitting in this beautiful
banana leaf bouquet and
they just kinda look like,
I don't know, little
sun flowery deliciousy--
- Yeah, little one biter eggs.
Oh yeah.
I love 'em.
- It tastes like fried eggs.
There's nothing--
- If you love fried eggs, there's no way
you won't love fried quail eggs.
- [Mike] Yeah and it's fried
really well so the yolk
is not too runny, which I don't like.
It's not too hard.
- It's a little starchy.
And then you can also taste, she added,
she sprinkled on some soy
sauce, like soy sauce.
And it's called maggi sauce.
- [Mike] I feel like this
needs some chili, I don't know.
- [Mark] Chili would be good.
Since we happen to be sitting at a table
that has some chili
vinegar, we might as well
make use of our resources.
- It's a little too sour for the egg but--
- That's a jolt of sourness.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That'll wake you up.
- Maybe don't do that.
But these fried fish cakes,
these are ridiculous.
- I really like both of them.
- Woah, woah, woah.
Dare we?
- [Mark] Mike just had the brilliant idea
to combine the both snacks on one skewer.
Did you get some basil in that bite, man?
- [Mike] I'm gonna.
- [Mark] Dude, dude--
- [Mike] I'm gonna get some basil.
- [Mark] Fish in there,
man, fish in there.
Oh, there we go.
- [Mike] And I wanna dip
the egg in that sauce.
- Cucumber on the tip?
- Here's to innovation.
- Oh yeah, cheers man.
- That's where it's at.
- That's a winner.
I'm always a huge fan of
especially quail eggs.
Quail eggs are wonderful little
bite size of just pureness.
Can we try some of these?
(speaking foreign language)
This thing is called
(speaks foreign language0
and this is a snack that's not
all that common everywhere.
And they're kinda like little curry puffs.
- [Mike] They look like little dumplings.
- Yeah, just little
perfect bite size snacks.
- Why's the fish?
The fish is like jerky.
- Yep, I think it's dried fish.
- [Mike] It's good.
- It's kinda like a cross between
a dessert and a savory snack.
It's like one of those
things that's kinda sweet
but it's very oniony and
garlicy at the same time.
- It's good, it's good.
I don't know if I can eat
a whole bag full of those
but it's good.
- Me too, me too, it's okay.
(speaking foreign language)
Yeah, we do need to definitely try this.
Mike and I are stopping for the next snack
and this is kind of a
Thai innovative snack
cause it has cheese on it.
So we've got scallops and
then it looks like she--
(speaking foreign language)
Cream cheese.
- [Mike] Cream cheese.
- Oh so there's cream cheese
and then there's fresh cheese.
And then she grills them over the fire
and then yeah, they're just
very very small scallops.
This is more of a modern Thai snack,
a very modern Thai snack.
And then she just said she's gonna
add on some seafood sauce.
She said we gotta eat it hot and fast
so it's very hot in our
fingers, right off the grill.
That cheese is all melty and oozy.
All right man, we just
gotta scrape it off.
- Let's do it.
Oh.
- Mmm.
(speaking foreign language)
- That's amazing, you are awesome.
- That is actually awesome.
I got a little bit of
caramelized cheese on the shell.
- That's my favorite, that's
my favorite right now.
- We don't want any of
that to go to waste.
- [Mike] One of the best
things I've had this week.
- [Mark] Wow, that's delicious.
- Maybe it's because the
cheese is so gooey and good
and I'm partial to that but
that's scallops got some
beautiful sweet flavor.
(speaking foreign language)
So guys, remember Mr. Boy Scallops.
Wow.
- So yeah, Mr. Boy Scallop.
This market is pretty packed, though.
You will, when you come
here, you'll definitely
be with a lot of people.
It gets pretty sweaty in
some of these alleys as well
but you can smell all
the aromas of the food
and it's so worth it.
We've been snacking for awhile already
but we're only now making it
to the main canal, the Amphawa
canal and this is where the
floating market happens.
These are where the boats are.
So right along the
canal, within the water,
they have a number of different boats.
Also, serving a variety
of different things.
They have pad Thai, they
have different noodles,
they have different
seafood, just fresh seafood
which is grilled and then they do have
sort of like, almost like stadium seating
where you can, if you're
lucky, you can grab a seat.
It's kinda packed and
kinda tricky to get a seat
but I think we'll be able to get a seat.
(upbeat music)
(speaking foreign language)
- We just got pretty much front row seats.
It almost feels like
we're at a sports game.
And these are bleachers and then they have
all the boats serving
food but when Mike and I
are ordering together, I think we got
every seafood that is visible.
We got the jumbo prawns,
we got squid, we got crab
and we got a whole fish.
- Yeah, well, you don't want
any food regret, you know?
You wanna get everything you can.
You'd rather get too much than too little.
- You wanna get everything you see.
- Yeah, otherwise you're like, man I wish
I got that fish the other day.
- Oh, I totally forgot
about the fish, man.
- [Mike] This is bad.
- We don't have any square
space of table left.
- [Mike] This is an experience
that I needed to have in Thailand.
- What do you wanna begin with?
- I think we should do
the calamare because
that's what the fly is attacking the most.
- Oh yeah, all right.
Let's do it.
Man they grilled this squid up.
You can see it on the boat,
just the big pieces of squid
and what's cool about this piece of squid
is that there's eggs in it.
Can you see those squid eggs?
It's just stuffed with eggs.
- [Mike] All right, so
dip it in the sauce.
- All right, seafood sauce, dipping.
Oh wow.
- Oh my God, it's good.
- [Mark] It's like a little
bit leathery in texture
but it's not chewy and then the eggs
are almost like jellyish.
- Yeah and they kinda
like give you that nice,
because usually when
you eat squid, it's like
chewing all over the rubber
and all that's in your mouth.
That's the only texture you taste.
But you got the nice beautiful soft eggs.
Oh, that's glorious.
How bout we get into
these big bad boys here?
- Yeah, let's do this.
These are river prawns here.
Actually the heads are pretty big,
but they are pretty decently sized.
- [Mike] These are like river monsters.
- I'm gonna break this guy
open, take off the head
and actually the best thing
about eating river prawns
is what's in the head.
- [Mike] You gonna eat the head?
- Oh yeah, but actually
you can almost break
off that head shell there.
What I like to do is tear off
that outer shell and then just
kinda suck up that head
butter juices, right in there.
Look at that.
- I'm gonna take a lesson
from the master here.
- Oh yeah man, that's the
good stuff right there.
- Okay so what do we do, we
just put the sauce in there?
- Just suck it.
You can or you can just
taste the pureness of it.
- Okay, I'll do, this is my first time.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- [Mike] It's almost very eggy.
- [Mark] It's shrimp pudding.
It's a little bit bitter,
it's awfully good.
Oh yeah.
- Sweet succulent flesh, my friend.
- Just so meaty.
- [Mike] Let's jump on the crab.
What kind of crabs are these?
- [Mark] In Thai it's called
(speaks foreign language).
- [Mike] It looks a
little like stone crab,
at least the claws do, look
a little like stone crab.
- This crab is one of my
favorite things from the sea.
Look at the size of his claw, man.
- Yeah, it's awesome.
- It's pretty decently sized.
- That's pretty.
- [Mark] And they've cracked it already
so should be semi-easy
for us to eat it all.
Look at that drumstick.
And you have to just
give this another dunking
in the seafood sauce.
Oh that works like a mitt to
scoop up some of that sauce.
- That's some sweet
crustacean right there.
- All the like stringiness of the crab
while being silky at the same time.
- That's fresh, that's fresh.
You can tell that's fresh.
- [Mark] This is actually
just completely fantastic
just sitting here eating
seafood with Mike,
watching the boats, probably
such a relaxing to eat
'cause you can't really eat it too fast.
- Well you know what it is.
In China we have this saying called
(speaks foreign language)
which means eating for fun.
So the crab is one of those
foods that we consider,
you don't eat it to get full,
you eat it to enjoy yourself.
Almost like as an entertainment.
- It's a good thing we decided
to get the two crab platter.
- That is so sweet, man.
- It's really good.
- So sweet.
- And it's so meaty.
So in Thai this is called pla pao.
And this is a, let me get a
look at his face real fast.
It's a (speaks foreign language)
which is a barramundi fish.
What they do is they salt
press it, they actually fill it
with some herbs, there's
probably some lemongrass
and maybe some pandan leaves
within the cavity of the fish.
And then they coat it in a
salt in a big layer of salt.
And then they grill it on a fire.
- [Mike] Look at this, look
how flaky the flesh is.
Look how juicy that is, just falls apart.
So tender.
- [Mark] And then you gotta give this
a nice bath in the chili sauce.
- [Mike] Oh 100%, 100%.
Well I feel like this does
really beat the shrimp.
- [Mark] Yeah, it does.
- And that adds so much to the fish,
because there's so much more flavor.
One of my favorite things in Thailand.
- I eat it a lot too.
And also, not only is it good,
but it's actually very very healthy.
- Yeah.
- It's just pure fish, there's no oil.
There's no, it's just pure
fish so it's very healthy.
- [Mike] There's no fishy flavor to it
whatsoever, whatsoever.
It's so clean.
- We also got a couple
plates of green papaya salad.
This one is (speaks foreign language)
with crab and fermented fish sauce.
This was sort of just to change up
the flavor of the seafood.
- I mean you need something refreshing.
Well we gotta listen to our parents
and get our veggies a little bit.
- Yeah, that's pretty.
We just finished with that seafood feast
with the view of the boats
right from the boats.
The seafood was actually pretty good
but the food is not gonna
be the best Thai food
that you have when you eat from a boat.
You eat here mostly for the
atmosphere and the ambiance
and the novelty and the fun of it
which it definitely is very very fun.
But the food is okay, it's okay.
I think probably my
favorite thing was the crab.
The crab was actually really really good,
tasted quite fresh and
the meat was so sweet
and natural and fantastic actually.
(upbeat music)
You can just grab chilis at your will.
I cannot leave Thailand
without trying Miang kham.
- When I see people wrapping
something, I get excited.
- And it's such a colorful variety
of little tiny ingredients
that she chops up.
There's a whole little wedge of lime,
there's shallots in here, there's ginger,
there's toasted coconut
and then she adds the,
it's almost like a caramely
palm sugar dressing
that she puts in here
to wrap it all together.
- And I saw pieces of lime
in there, that's actual--
- It's actually a wedge
of lime, no, no, no,
you eat the skin and all so you can expect
like a jolt of sourness, citrusiness.
- And we each got a pepper, what do we do?
- We're gonna chase it with the chili.
Let's eat one and chase it.
Wanna chase it with the chili?
It's like vegetarian vegetable candy, man.
- Woah.
This is actually really remarkable.
- [Mark] It's awesome.
- [Mike] It's fragrant,
it's sour, it's sweet,
very flavorful.
- And we need more chili, she has
a whole bowl of chili over there.
- There you go.
- Oh thanks man, red or green?
I'll go green.
It's refreshing too.
- It's good stuff.
- Yeah, that is sweet but
it's something you really
have to try when you come to Thailand
because that mix of flavors,
that's like Thailand in a single bite.
(speaking foreign language)
You have a little thumb to ...
Oh that's cute, that's cute.
- I know this is not Thai food, Mark,
but I saw this and I couldn't resist.
It's got a little, look at
this, little thumb thing.
- It's a little mitt of little
bite size ice cream cones.
- One of my all time goals in life
is to eat an ice cream cone in one bite.
I'm just kidding, no one has
those goals like seriously.
But this looks delicious.
I'm gonna take a little green one.
- Wait, what's your flavor?
I'll go vanilla, maybe this is vanilla.
Yeah look at this, little bite sized.
- Oh, this is lime sorbet.
- Okay.
- Cheers to ice cream.
- Cheers, man, one biters?
- Yeah.
That was funner than I thought.
- It is pretty cool because you like smash
the entire cone as you bite down.
(speaking foreign language)
This is called (speaks foreign language)
which is a coconut milk custard.
And then this one is more
of an egg yolk custard.
That is very pretty.
- [Mike] That's beautiful,
that is beautiful.
- [Mark] So like the
traditional version of the snack
is served in little, almost
like bite size little
cupcakes with banana
leaves so they've kind of
made this kind of trendy
kind of beautiful.
And it's cool that you
get to keep the clay pot.
- [Mike] That's what's really
awesome about this is that
look and this is something
you'll buy in the US at a store.
What's the red stuff?
- [Mark] I have no idea.
- [Mike] No one knows.
- [Mark] Are you getting
some random pink stuff?
- [Mike] I'm getting the random pink.
Under is green.
What is this green stuff?
- [Mark] There's the
tapioca on the bottom,
tapioca and corn.
- [Mike] Woah, look at
the tapioca bubbles.
- [Mark] You keep digging
further and you get new things.
- [Mike] This is like an iceberg.
Most of what you don't
see is on the bottom.
- [Mark] Yeah look at the layers to that.
- This is beautiful.
I like it.
I'll tell you what, I like it.
- It is good.
- I wasn't so sure in
the first couple bites
when you're chewing it,
but you get the corn
that's kinda salty.
- [Mark] And they also add a lot of salt
to the actual coconut
cause that brings out
the flavor of the coconut.
- Yeah, and I think this is something also
that gets better as you chew it.
- [Mark] And there's also little pieces
within the bottom there,
there's corn and taro.
- [Mike] Oh, I just saw the taro.
- [Mark] Like little starchy
pieces of taro there.
- [Mike] Oh that's crazy.
- A lot of going on.
- There's tons of stuff going on here.
I mean, I'm almost expecting
to find like a prawn down here.
- [Mark] Oh man, that
would be a lucky bite.
I would love that bite.
- Little bit of a different
texture, little crunch.
- I got a bunch of taro in that bite.
- This is really good.
- [Mark] We found some
horseshoe crab salad.
In Thai it's called
(speaking foreign language).
You can't really eat
the actual crab because
it's rock hard shell, it's like
prehistoric looking creature
but what you eat are the
eggs from the backside
and then they mix it with green mango.
- [Mike] I see these on
beaches all the time.
Like all the time and
okay so they're not edible
in terms of their own flesh.
- [Mark] Grab one of those
nuggets on the side there.
- [Mike] I'm trying to actually avoid,
like can I get just a little sampler?
Dinosaur, think dinosaur.
- I love it.
- I have no idea what I just ate.
- They're almost like highly
concentrated egg yolks.
- It's just like beans to me.
- Like they're really
condensed, really like,
almost chalky and kind of yolky.
- [Mike[ It's not my favorite.
I think I'm stopping at one.
- [Mark] Oh man, I really love it.
- [Mike] I was really
hoping to eat the crab meat.
I mean I was hoping like
you'd crack this open
and there's some like untold sweet
succulent tender crab
meat I didn't know existed
and I just discovered like
a new wonderful crab but.
- We have been eating all afternoon
and that was a lot of fun.
What did you think about
the floating market, Mike?
- Well, I loved the food first of all.
And actually just be able to see it
because I never saw it before.
I heard concepts of
it, I've seen pictures,
never seen it in person and
it was great experience,
so thank you so much
for showing me around.
- Big thank you to Mike
for hanging out and eating.
He is Strictly Dumpling on YouTube
and I'll leave his link
in the description box.
Go check out his awesome food videos
and I wanna say a big thank
you to you for watching.
Please remember to give this video
a thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Would love to hear from you
in the comments section below
and if you're not already subscribed,
click subscribe now for lots
more food and travel videos.
Goodbye from Amphawa and we'll
see you on the next video.
Thank you again for watching.
- See you later.